[Music]  it's really great to be able to do this  on our national day we're in a group of  new New Zealand citizens for one night  really end Christchurch and with a  tonight offer Erie who are the local  subscribe poor Monica reading 12 from  one a kabillion for families and they  came from inside from around your er  from what cook to the beach  implementable so they were across the  district they're normally do in the  council chamber and we do it every  couple of months or so and they usually  about 30 at a time and it's always a  really important part of my job as mere  two square new citizens in and but its  first time we've done it here and it's  hope we can do it in and future  [Music]  [Music]